it would be interesting to hear how is
your concerned concern
evolved
with the coming out of Chad GPT
and these new large language models that
are fine-tuned with reinforcement
learning and seemingly to be able to do
some incredible human-like things
there's two questions one how is your
concern in terms of AGI and super
intelligence evolved and how impressed
are you with Chad gbt as a as a student
of the human mind in mind in general
well my concern about AGI is unchanged
and so I I did a I've spoken about it a
bunch on my podcast but you know I did a
TED Talk in 2016 which was the the kind
of summary of
what that conference and and you know
various conversations I had after that
did to my my brain on this topic
um basically that once super
intelligence is achieved there's a take
off it becomes exponentially smarter and
in a matter of time there's just we're
ants and they're Gods well yeah unless
we find some way of
to permanently tethering
a a self a a super intelligent super
intelligent self-improving AI to our
value system and I you know I don't
believe anyone has
figured out how to do that or whether
that's even possible in principle I know
people like Stuart Russell who I just
had on my podcast
um are oh really have You released it I
haven't released it yet yeah he's been
on previous podcasts but we just
recorded this week because you haven't
done an AI podcast in a while so yeah
it's great yeah he's a good person to
talk about alignment with yeah so Stuart
I mean Stewart has has been you know
probably more than anyone my Guru on
this topic I mean like just reading his
book and and doing I think I've done two
podcasts with them at this point I think
it's called the control problem or
something like that his is uh his book
is human compatible human compatible
yeah he talks about the control problem
and
yeah so I just think the idea that we
can define a value function in advance
that permanently tethers a a
self-improving super intelligent AI to
R values as we continue to
discover them refine them extrapolate
them
in an open-ended way
I think that's a tall order and there I
think there are many more ways there
must be many more ways of Designing
super intelligence that is not aligned
in that way and is not ever
approximating our values in that way so
I mean Stewart's idea to
put it in a very simple way is that
he thinks you don't want to specify the
value function up front you don't you
don't want to imagine you could ever
write the code
in such a way as to admit of no loophole
you want to
make the AI uncertain as to what human
values are and perpetually uncertain and
always trying to ameliorate that
uncertainty by by hewing more and more
closely to what our professed values are
so like this it's always interested in
uh saying oh no no that's not what we
want that's not what we intend stop
doing that right like no matter how
smart it gets all it wants to do is more
perfectly approximate human values I
think there are a lot of problems with
that you know at a high level I'm not a
computer scientist so I'm sure there are
many problems at a low level that I
don't understand or like how to force
the human into the loop always no matter
what there's that and like what humans
get a vote and just just what is you
know uh what what do humans value and
what is the difference between well we
say we value and our revealed
preferences which I mean if you just if
you were a super intelligent AI they
could look at
Humanity now
I think you could be forgiven for
concluding that what we value is
driving ourselves crazy with Twitter and
living perpetually on the brink of
nuclear war and you know just watching
you know hot girls in yoga pants on Tick
Tock again and again it's like when
you're saying that is not this is this
is all revealed preference and it's what
is an AI to make of that right and what
should it optimize like so
and part of the this is also Stewart's
observation that
one of the Insidious things about like
the YouTube algorithm is it's not that
it just caters
to our preferences it actually begins to
change Us in ways so as to make us more
predictable it's like it finds ways to
make us a better reporter of our of our
preferences uh and to trim our
preferences down so that it can can
uh further train to that signal so
the main concern is that
most of the people in the field seem not
to be taking
intelligence seriously like as as they
design
more and more intelligent machines and
as they profess to want to design true
AGI
they're not
again they're not spending the time that
Stewart is spending trying to figure out
how to do this safely above all
they're just assuming that these
these problems are going to solve
themselves as we as we make that final
stride into the end zone or they're
saying very
you know pollyanish things like you know
an AI would never form a motive to harm
human like why would it ever form a
motive to
to be malicious toward Humanity right
unless we put that motive in there right
and that's that's not the concern the
concern is that in the presence of
of vast disparities and competence
and in certainly in a condition where
these the machines are improving
themselves they're improving their own
code they could be developing goal
instrumental goals
that are antithetical to our well-being
without any without any intent to harm
us right it's it's analogous to what we
do to
every other species on Earth I mean you
and I don't consciously form the
intention
to harm insects on a daily basis but
there are many things we could intend to
do that would in fact harm insects
because you know you decide to repave
your driveway or whatever whatever
you're doing you're like you're not
you're just not
taking the the interests of insects into
account because they're so far beneath
you in terms of your cognitive Horizons
and the so that the real challenge here
is that
if you believe that intelligence you
know scales up on a Continuum to toward
Heights that
we can only dimly imagine and I think
there's every reason to believe that
there's no reason to believe that we're
near the summit of intelligence
um and you can Define you know Define
maybe maybe there's
maybe there's some forms of intelligence
for which this is not true but
for for many relevant forms you know
like the top 100 things we care about
cognitively I think there's every reason
to believe that many of those things
most of those things
are a lot like chess or go where once
the machines get better than we are
they're going to stay better than we are
although they're I don't know if you
caught the recent thing with go where
and this guy actually came out of
Stewart's lab yeah yeah yeah uh one time
a human beat a machine and yeah they
found a hack for that but anyway in the
ultimately it's there's going to be no
looking back and then the question is
what do we do in relate in relationship
to these systems that are more competent
than we are in every relevant respect
because it will be a relationship it's
not like the people the people who think
we're just going to figure this all out
you know without thinking about it in
advance it's just gonna these the
solutions are just gonna find themselves
um
seem not to be taking
the prospect of really creating
autonomous super intelligence seriously
like like what does that mean it's every
bit as
independent and ungovernable ultimately
as us having created I mean just imagine
if we created a race of people that were
10 times smarter than all of us like how
would we live with those people they're
10 times smarter than us right like they
begin to talk about things we don't
understand they begin to want things we
don't understand they begin to view us
as obstacles to them so they're solving
those problems or gratifying those
desires
we become the chickens or the monkeys in
their presence and
I think that
it's but for some amazing solution of
the sort that Stuart is is imagining
that we could somehow anchor their
reward function permanently no matter
how intelligent scales I think um it's
it's really worth worrying about this I
do I do buy the the you know the Sci-Fi
uh notion that this is an existential
risk if we don't do it well I worry that
we don't notice it I'm I'm deeply
impressed with Chad GPT and I'm worried
that it will become super intelligent
these language models have become super
intelligent because they're basically
trained in the collective intelligence
of the human species and then it'll
start controlling our Behavior if
they're integrated into our algorithms
the recommender systems and then we just
won't notice
that there's a super intelligent system
that's controlling our Behavior
well I think that's true even before far
before super intelligence even before
general intelligence I mean I think just
the narrow intelligence
of these algorithms and of what
something like you know chat GPT can can
do
um
I mean it's just
far
short of it developing its own goals and
that is that are at Cross purposes with
ours just the just the unintended
consequences of of using it in the ways
we're going to be incentivized to use it
and and you know the money to be made
from scaling this thing and what it does
to to our information space and our
sense of of just being able to get the
ground truth of
of Iran on any facts it's um
yeah it's it's super scary and it was
it's do you think it's a giant leap in
terms of the development towards AGI
Chad GPT or we still
um is this just an impre impressive
little
toolbox so like what what do you think
the singularity is coming
or is it to you doesn't matter
eventually I have no intuitions on that
front apart from the fact that if we
continue to make progress it will come
right so it's just you just have to
assume we continue to make progress
there's only two assumptions you you
have to assume substrate Independence so
there's no reason why this can't be done
in silico it's just it's just we can
build arbitrarily intelligent machines
there's nothing magical about having
having this done in in the wet wear of
our own brains
I think that is true and I think that's
a you know scientifically parsimonious
to think that that's true
um and then you just have to assume
we're going to keep making progress it
doesn't have to be any special rate of
progress doesn't have to be Moore's Law
it can just be we just keep going at a
certain point we're going to be in
relationship to Minds leaving
Consciousness Consciousness aside I I
don't I don't have any reason to believe
that
they'll necessarily be conscious by
virtue of being super intelligent and
that's its own interesting ethical
question but
uh
leaving conscience aside
they're going to be more they're going
to be more competent than we are and
then that's like you know the aliens
have landed you know that's literally
that's an encounter
with again leaving aside the possibility
that that something like Stewart's
path is is is uh actually available to
us uh but it is hard to picture
if what we mean by intelligence All
Things Considered and it's truly General
um
if that scales and
you know begins to
build upon itself how you
maintain
that perfect slavish devotion Until the
End of Time the tethering those systems
that tells you humans yeah I think my
gut says that that tether is not there's
a lot of ways to do it
so it's not this increasingly impossible
problem
right so I have no you know you know as
you know I'm not a computer scientist I
have no intuitions about just
algorithmically how you would approach
that and what's somewhat spot my main
intuition is uh maybe deeply flawed but
the main nutrition is based on the fact
that most of the learning is currently
happening on human knowledge
so even Chad GPT is just trained on
human data right
I I don't see where the takeoff happens
where you completely go above human
wisdom the current impressive aspect of
child gpts that's using collective
intelligence of all of us
from what what I glean from again from
people who know much more about this
than I do I I
think we have reason to be skeptical
that these Tech techniques of you know
deep learning
are actually going to be sufficient to
push us into AGI right so it's just not
they're not
they're not generalizing in the way they
need to they're not certainly not
learning like human children and so
they're they're
there's brittle and strange ways there
there
um it's not to say that the human path
is the only path you know and you know
and maybe there's we might learn better
lessons by ignoring the way brains work
but
um
we know that they don't generalize and
use
abstraction the way we do and so
um although they have strange holes in
their competence but the size of the
holes is shrinking every time and that's
so the intuition starts to slowly fall
apart you know the intuition is like
surely it can't be this simple to
achieve super intelligence yeah but it's
becoming simpler and simpler so I don't
know I don't the progress is quite
incredible I've been extremely impressed
with Chad GPT and the new models and
there's a lot of financial incentive to
make progress on this regard so it's
we're going to be living through some
very interesting times